[Música]
fue un anuncio controvertido hablo del
anuncio del levantamiento del título 42
de la ley federal de salud que fue
anunciado por el presidente de eeuu joe
biden una decisión que no termina de
convencer a muchos sectores del gobierno
incluso de su mismo partido levantar
este artículo permite entonces reanudar
los procesos migratorios entre ellos por
ejemplo la solicitud de asilo político
en las fronteras del país estos procesos
fueron suspendidos todo esto en el marco
de este título 42 como una medida para
hacer frente a la pandemia del joven 19
así lo explica por lo menos el
comunicado de prensa que fue emitido por
el homeland security firmado por el
secretario de seguridad nacional
alejandro mayorkas
el título 42 no es una medida migratoria
sino una medida de salud pública que
utilizaron los centros para el control y
prevención de enfermedades para
protegernos de la propagación de
enfermedades transmisibles el título 42
se mantiene vigente hasta el 23 de mayo
y hasta entonces el departamento de
seguridad nacional de eeuu continuará
expulsando a los individuos adultos y
familias que encontremos con estatus
irregular en nuestra frontera suroeste
bueno es claro hasta el 23 de mayo
entonces el artículo 42 puede seguir
vigente sin embargo al interior del
partido demócrata hay varios sectores
que le piden al presidente de bailén que
mantenga la norma y ni que decir por
supuesto dentro de los republicanos que
también han planteado la posibilidad de
proponer enmiendas para que el título se
convierta en un proyecto de ley
creo que tendrá que haber una enmienda
al título 42 para poder mover el
proyecto de ley
hay varias otras enmiendas que queremos
ofrecer por lo que tendremos que entrar
en algún tipo de acuerdo para procesar
estas enmiendas con el fin de seguir
adelante con el proyecto de ley los 21
estados de la unión americana han
rechazado los esfuerzos del gobierno
federal en la ciudad de washington para
derogar este título consideran que el
título 42 es un asunto de seguridad
nacional
21 estados como les estaba diciendo solo
por mencionar algunos de los que están
en la lista
alabama alaska arkansas florida georgia
kansas kentucky nebraska ohio tennessee
yuta wyoming solamente por nombrar
algunos de los estados que están en
contra de este levantamiento de este
título 42
pues ya lo decíamos porque están
entonces estos estados en esa posición
porque prefieren que se mantenga el
título 42 en que los beneficia también
una vez derogado el título 42 a partir
del 23 de mayo que es la fecha que han
dado las autoridades en washington
entrará en vigor el título 8 que es el
título de procedimiento estándar en las
fronteras para expulsar del país a un
individuo según sea su caso bajo este
parámetro de ley el temor que reina
entonces es que los traficantes de
personas hagan de las suyas comiencen
nuevamente también las caravanas desde
centroamérica y desde ya han comenzado a
notarse represamiento de personas en las
ciudades fronterizas del lado mexicano
principalmente en la ciudad de reynosa
hay también una gran presión sobre la
administración del presidente bailen por
la falta de un plan confiable para
manejar esta situación en la frontera
para manejar el arribo de miles de
inmigrantes sobre todo hay presión por
las discrepancias que ha generado
entonces al interior del gobierno al
interior de los mismos demócratas como
lo estábamos diciendo pues las
discrepancias que hay
al levantamiento del título 42 es
nuestro tema de debate soy santiago
lópez gonzález bienvenidos al programa y
para analizar este tema hemos invitado a
maría herrera ella es vicepresidenta de
la asamblea hispana republicana en la
florida ella se encuentra en la ciudad
de miami y en la ciudad de washington
está con nosotros mauren meyer ella es
vicepresidenta para programas de wola
una organización líder en investigación
e incidencia que promueve también los
derechos humanos en el continente
americano ustedes también nuestros
televidentes pueden participar en este
debate con todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas lo pueden hacer a través de
las redes sociales no se encuentran en
facebook en instagram y en twitter
estamos como france24 guión bajo ese
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal y
nuestra etiqueta es numeral el debate
efe 24 esperamos todos sus comentarios y
sus preguntas en torno a este tema
comienzo entonces con maría herrera
nuestra primera invitada le doy la
bienvenida al programa gracias por estar
con nosotros
en el programa de hoy y maría
el artículo 42 o título 42 ha demostrado
tener algún tipo de efectividad en este
tiempo que ha sido implementado ha
demostrado servir
por desgracia no porque la incompetencia
de esta administración ha llevado a una
entrada masiva y desordenada el mes de
marzo ha batido el récord histórico el
peor año de entrada masiva ilegal y
desordenada de inmigrantes por la
frontera sur desde que nació el
ministerio de seguridad nacional más de
220 mil personas han llegado a nuestras
fronteras desde que bardem es presidente
más de 1.5 millones un incremento del
300 por ciento de la misma fecha desde
que estaba donald trump en el poder lo
que estamos viviendo una crisis muy
grave yo he entrevistado a tuve la
oportunidad de hablar yo soy abogada de
inmigración trabajo en arizona nuevo
méxico y texas y tuve hablar tuve la
oportunidad de hablar con el presidente
de guatemala el doctor alejandro
giammatei que me dijo que esta
administración no sólo les ha pedido a
guatemala que detengan las caravanas en
la inmigración ilegal sino que no les ha
mandado un céntimo para perseguir a
aquellos traficantes de seres humanos y
traficantes
de drogas realmente preocupante lo que
vivimos y mauren en la ciudad de
washington en la capital de eeuu sus
impresiones ha servido para algo este
título o 42 en que ha sido útil a lo
largo de este tiempo que estuvo en
efecto que como ya lo decíamos comenzó
durante la administración del presidente
de donald trump como una medida para
mitigar el impacto de la pandemia del
cob y 19
dijo que ha servido para bloquear el
exceso a la protección a gente huyendo
de violencia en persecución en sus
países de origen a entrar en eeuu
realmente les estaban negando el derecho
de acceder al asilo en los eeuu para la
mayor la gente ha expulsado más de 1.7
millones de personas desde que centro en
vigor y lo que muestra también por la
gran cantidad de gente que sigue
llorando es que no está disuadiendo a la
gente salir de sus países de origen oa
la desesperación que tienen de buscar
mejor vida y también mucha gente busca
protección y gente que está huyendo por
por temor de su vida pues yo creo que
eso no ha funcionado y tampoco ha
mostrado ser un tema de salud pública no
sé yo creo que la condena en eeuu tiene
sus propios matices y justamente parte
la justificación de por qué levantarlo
ahorita es por la situación de poder
controlar la pandemia de acceso a
vacunas de acceso a tratamientos que
muestra como han dicho muchos expertos
en salud pública desde el inicio de la
implementación 10 ó 42 no hay una forma
de dejar a la gente entrar en el país
solicitar protección y proteger la salud
pública
mauren continuó con usted para hacer la
ronda a la inversa y le preguntó
entonces por las discrepancias que
genera esto al interior del partido de
los demócratas que es el partido del
presidente vaivén porque hay
discrepancias en y no rodean al
presidente en torno a esta decisión de
levantar este título y cuál es la
necesidad de bailén de tener que
levantar este título
yo creo por un lado o aumente su
necesidad de que es una medida de salud
pública no de control fronterizo si
quisieran tendrían que buscar otro
mecanismo para ampliar la seguro en la
frontera por otro lado y creo que lo que
preocupa es la percepción de que podría
crear más desorden en la frontera yo
creo que la gran prueba de algo grande
baines como asegurar que tenga las
instalaciones en los eeuu de la frontera
como tener el personal para poder
procesar a la gente de forma oportuna y
también este poder procesar sus casos
para que no estén quedando en eeuu en
234 años de incertidumbre sobre su
estatus por ejemplo en casos de estilo
yo creo que en la preocupación que
tienen algunos demócratas es que no han
visto
plan concreto de cómo asegurar desde con
el bar en que tenga toda la
infraestructura necesaria para evitar
las grandes personas y cantidad de
personas esperan que van a llorar y de
no poder procesarlos de una forma
oportuna y respetando sus derechos
y mariah su opinión porque genera estos
discrepancias al interior de los
demócratas está el gobierno proponiendo
algún plan de acción para mitigar el
impacto que pueda generar el momento en
el que se levante el título 42
porque estás claro que por mucho partido
que quieran anteponer lo que está nuevo
en la seguridad nacional y el futuro de
este país vivimos de nuevo repito la
peor crisis migratoria humanitaria desde
que existe el ministerio de seguridad
nacional en un país además donde los
índices de delincuencia donde además la
entrada de droga está completamente
descontrolada hacen tan y los
metanfetaminas y lo que hace el título
42 como bien dijo mi colega es detener a
muchas personas que sigan entrando pero
lo que estamos viendo y se lo puedo
asegurar es que realmente en la práctica
aunque se están reportando muchísimas a
muchísimos cientos de miles de
inmigrantes son números récord estamos
hablando de sólo del triángulo norte de
centroamérica ha entrado están entrando
88 mil personas en el mes de marzo 16
mil niños los incrementos son increíbles
y lo que pasa es que los los políticos
los
candidatos demócratas y aquellos que
están representando a sus distritos en
los senados en los estatales a nivel
federal se juegan su puesto en el
noviembre de 2022 y saben que van a
perder porque porque esto no se puede
contener porque la presión que están
viviendo estados como méxico nuevo
méxico texas arizona es insostenible el
ex jefe de la patrulla fronteriza del
ministerio de seguridad nacional dijo
que 1000 detención y 1000 entradas
diarias al país pone a la patrulla
fronteriza en una situación difícil
estamos rondando las 18.000 entradas
diarios cuando se levanta este título ya
tenemos a 25.000 inmigrantes listos para
entrar sin ningún tipo de control porque
les tengo que decir que además ni
siquiera en muchos casos están haciendo
la entrevista del miedo creíble porque
no hay suficiente personal y que decir
cuando entran y tenemos casi dos
millones de atrás son los tribunales
donde los inmigrantes llegan y ni
siquiera se pueden reportar a la policía
de inmigración para hacer un chequeo
tardan meses y años y darle una
oportunidad para solicitar el asilo en
fin yo creo que lo que estamos viviendo
es muy grave los demócratas y los
demócratas saben que el caos que han
organizado esta administración en
concreto yo va a ir en una cámara harry
es la jefa de la frontera que ni
siquiera ha ido más de una vez a la
frontera a reunirse con tres chicas
centroamericana un secretario mallorca
que desde la casa blanca ha incitado al
tráfico de menores diciendo que todos
los menores que vengan aquí serán
recibidos que ha hecho eso el
contrabando de menores es muy grave lo
que estamos viviendo y los demás están
aterrorizados maría que se puede
proponer entonces desde la parte
republicana ya lo veíamos en la
introducción del programa han habido ha
habido algunas ideas en torno a hacer
enmiendas a este título 42 para
promoverlo como un proyecto de ley es
esto viable dentro de la legislación de
eeuu es algo que la bancada republicana
puede llegar a contemplar la posibilidad
de promover al interior del congreso
mire yo no lo sé yo creo que hay que
diferenciar y está claro que existe una
diferencia entre los temas de control
fronterizo y las leyes de salud pública
estamos en una coyuntura es cierto el
coronavirus pero yo creo que lo que hay
que tener ahora mismo de seguro lo
tienes muy claro los republicanos y los
demócratas es que hay que defender
nuestras fronteras que aquí no puede
entrar todo el mundo porque le digo no
es que esté entrando son los hispanos
que vengan pero siguen perseguidos de
perseguidos políticos están entrando
rusos africanos asiáticos personas que
ven en esa frontera una debilidad lo que
los republicanos están están proponiendo
está claro hay que sellar nuestras
fronteras que ha hecho el gobernador
greg abbott bueno mire si ustedes no
quieren ayudarnos a construir el muro si
usted no quieren que protestamos
protejamos el dinero nuestro
contribuyente nosotros le vamos a mandar
los inmigrante a washington dc y a
maryland y delaware el gobernador de
florida que ha propuesto ha dicho mire
nosotros vamos a poner a la guardia
nacional a disposición del estado de
texas y aquí no vamos a hacer que los
contribuyentes de florida gas más dinero
en educación gratuita para menores que
usted están atrayendo ustedes están
haciendo un efecto llamada los
republicanos no tienen claro los
demócratas cada vez más porque saben que
se juegan su puesto y porque saben y
esta es la realidad que la gestión de
bailén está llevando a un imposible para
llegar a ningún tipo de reforma
inmigratoria en el congreso en el senado
porque más que nunca estamos temerosos
por nuestros bolsillos por nuestra
frontera por nuestro futuro y no va a
haber ningún acuerdo migratorio
mauren desde su punto de vista este tipo
de ley es la prolongación de esta ley o
los límites que acerca esta ley dentro
del marco migratorio de eeuu y dentro de
la salud pública porque para eso fue
puesto este título con motivo de la
pandemia de kobe 19 hay algún tipo de
violaciones de derechos humanos que esta
gente esté allí acumulándose en la
frontera con mexico ya hemos visto que
cada vez más personas llegan a ciudades
como reynosa en el norte de méxico y se
han tomado algunos parques y los
campamentos de migrantes han comenzado a
crecer en la parte humanitaria y de
derechos hay algún tipo de violaciones o
temas que debamos tener en consideración
allí
pues ponente y burlado está empeorando
su derecho de protección en los eeuu las
expulsiones a méxico ha provocado más de
10.000 delitos y violaciones de derechos
de la gente expulsada violaciones
sexuales secuestros otros abusos de la
gente teniendo que esperar para poder
entrar en eeuu o pensar en que pueden
hacer ahora están otra vez varados en
méxico creo que también importante es
decir que incluso la forma de procesar a
la gente y luego expulsarles en
autobuses otra vez en méxico provocó un
medicamento y también gente que se
contagió de por pandemia justamente a
las políticas de eeuu se está ofreciendo
vacunas a toda la gente que está
entrando bajo un nuevo si se cuando se
levante el título cuál es de dos vacunas
a la gente hay forma de hacerlo para
hacer pruebas de kobe ya lo han hecho
experimentos la sociedad civil en el
lado de eeuu donde ya está lista para
apoyar a las personas que están llegando
para hacerles pruebas para apoyar en su
traslado a otros lugares en el país yo
creo que yo derechos humanos sí pero
violando el derecho de poder pedir
protección y creo que es importante y
pensar que el gobierno de paren quiere
que a nivel regional vemos el tema de
migración y protección como una
responsiva compartida ahorita el
secretario de estado
linkin están panamá una reunión
ministerial hablando de cómo manejar la
migración a nivel regional incluye
acceso de protección eeuu no puede pedir
a otros países a recibir a más y más
gente huyendo de violencia y estados
están mantiene cerrada su frontera yo
creo que frente a un panorama de la
llegada de gente no vista antes a la
frontera e incluyendo muchas personas de
sudamérica de venezolanos de colombianos
el mes pasado aprendieron que tuvieron
30 mil cubanos en la frontera con eeuu
están llegando gente de muchas
diferentes nacionalidades no solamente
en méxico y centroamérica
estamos ante una una movida humana muy
grande en la región y en eso creo que
cada país tiene que ver qué es
incluyendo eeuu en poder ofrecer
protección a gente que de este país el
mejor lugar para asegurarse ellos y sus
familias mauren y en ese panorama que
usted nos describe entran en unos
señalamientos y unas críticas hechas
hechas precisamente al gobierno de eeuu
por el ingreso de los ciudadanos
ucranianos entendemos el contexto en el
que se encuentra a ucrania víctima de
una invasión por parte de rusia pero al
dos ucranianos se han podido entrar a
eeuu con el estatus de asilados
políticos y muchos han llegado a través
de la frontera con mexico muchos han
llegado a través del territorio mexicano
y centroamericano hasta la frontera sur
de eeuu
estos señalamientos a nivel
internacional dejan a eeuu mal parado
que si deja entrar a los ucranianos pero
siguen manteniendo por fuera de la
frontera a los africanos suramericanos
cubanos que están allí en méxico
esperando desde hace muchos meses
y por nada parece algo muy racial no
podemos volar a haití un país que ha
sufrido muchos desastres naturales
sufriendo asesinatos su presidente año
pasado pero volamos a 20.000 haitianos
desde septiembre por primera vez este
año bajo el título 42 pero estamos
aceptando a los super anios claro que la
situación es muy grave en ucrania el
gore de vaina ofrecido a
dar acogida a cien mil ucranianos muchos
con estatus que no es así los una
protección humanitaria para entrar en
los eeuu pero si da la imagen de que es
un doble estándar y si eeuu puede
procesar a cientos de personas de frank
ya cada día en la frontera con eeuu
muestra que también lo podrían hacer con
personas de otras nacionalidades y no es
justo que gente que también está viendo
de mucha violencia y persecución están
esperando en ciudades muy peligrosas en
mexico para tener la misma oportunidad
que las personas de ucrania anterior
actualmente
mariah que hay de esa responsabilidad
compartida ya mauren hablaba de esta
reunión de blind king en panamá para
hablar sobre el tema
con funcionarios de los gobiernos de la
región eeuu claramente no puede cargar
con todo este peso de recibir a todas
las personas que llegan o que quieran
entrar a su territorio a través de la
frontera con méxico pero que puede hacer
estados unidos en conjunto con países
como méjico o como ya estaba trabajando
con honduras el salvador y guatemala
estos planes en que quedaron ahora
después de la pandemia esto se vuelve a
reactivar esto sigue en marcha como
están estos planes pues es que lo estaba
comentando en la entrevista que tuve con
el presidente de guatemala este gobierno
no le interesa que los centroamericanos
ni nome ni los mexicanos detenga las
caravanas de personas la inmigración
ilegal señores que no están dando ni un
solo dólar que lo que puso con donald
trump los acuerdos para llegar a un país
seguro para cooperar para en vez de dar
en miles de millones de dólares estos
países en ayuda al desarrollo es sin
pedir nada a cambio que se tiene que
detener el tráfico de menores de mujeres
el tráfico de droga que esta
administración ha desmantelado cualquier
plan que se están violando los derechos
de los inmigrantes gracias a que esta
administración está dejando que en los
inmigrantes transitan libremente es que
se las intensiones que se les violen con
respecto al tps yo me gustaría recordar
que en este país no sólo se da de psa
los ucranianos señores venezolanos
323.000 el salvador- 251.000 honduras
80.000 haití 56 mil nepal 14 mil 77 mil
y podría seguir lo que no se puede
permitir es que si la mayoría de
inmigrantes que vengan son inmigrantes
económicos muchas veces que piden asilo
y no haya ningún tipo de control
fronterizo y que estamos viviendo una
coyuntura económica muy delicada así una
coyuntura sanitaria pero que esto no se
puede permitir que eeuu nuevos países
más generosos del mundo y que el resto
de países tendrá que ver porque cuando
yo ayudo a honduras hace un mes y medio
el 90% de la población
clara y potencialmente un inmigrante
porque no quiere seguir viviendo en este
país en ese país porque por el tema del
narcotráfico por la falta de
oportunidades que hacemos lo que hay que
hacer es llevar a cabo una lucha contra
la corrupción de una forma objetiva no
metiendo a nuestros candidatos y metidos
nuestras políticas en otros países
respetando la soberanía de los países y
sobre todo colaborando con países que
tienen la capacidad o cuyos líderes se
han ofrecido a recibir como el caso de
bando que ahora eso sí lo que tenemos
que tener claro es que este precio la
inmigración ilegal y desordenada y
masiva lo van a apagar los los políticos
en las urnas porque no hay manera no hay
país en el mundo que pueda seguir
acogiendo a estos millones de
inmigrantes
2.5 millones de inmigrantes desde que yo
bailé llegó a la casa blanca seguimos y
bajo el disfraz o del derecho
humanitario estamos acogiendo aquí
personas políticas que abusan que abusan
del sistema y por cierto en esta semana
sentándonos en la mesa con una narco
dictadura como es la de díaz canel para
negociar de exportaciones de cubanos
a cuba lo que estamos viviendo es una
auténtica locura lo que está haciendo
este gobierno de baile maría usted habla
de las urnas precisamente hay elecciones
en eeuu el 8 de noviembre muchos le han
planteado al presidente debaten que
posponga a levantar el título 42 después
de esa fecha por usted lo mencionado el
peso que esto representa para los
políticos locales esto no solamente le
va a pasar factura a los demócratas en
estos comicios ven ustedes en riesgo
para los candidatos republicanos en
algunos estados en los estados que van
era a estos comicios en noviembre por
este tema no los republicano están
clarísimos seguridad fronteriza por
encima de todo en nuestra casa entre a
quien nosotros digamos en las
condiciones que nosotros digamos y una
vez que hayan demostrado que son
perseguidos políticos que tienen un
testimonio certero real que vienen con
la documentación en regla sino no entra
nadie para el partido demócrata está
completamente secuestrado por el haga
radical sino no tiene ningún sentido la
incompetencia en la frontera señores le
repito
de la frontera en los eeuu kamala harris
la señora vicepresidenta ha ido una vez
a la frontera y se ha ido a ucrania a
defender la frontera de ucrania señora
kamala harris defienda las fronteras de
los estados unidos- defienda como dice
aquí mi colega los derechos humanos de
los verdaderos presos políticos no de
todo aquel que viene por la frontera
porque dice bueno es que mi país no hay
oportunidades económicas si no hay
oportunidades económicas yo cómo voy a
inmigración le digo que no hay ninguna
sola ley ni política ahora mismo
aplicable que le permite usted entrar de
esa forma usted tiene que ir a través de
una embajada un consulado una oferta
laboral un visado de trabajo estudiantes
conozcan la ley lo que pasa es que
kamala harris es una persona que tiene
cero experiencia en materia de fronteras
de política fronteriza y si hablamos del
secretario mallorca que se atrevió a
decir con un altavoz vengan todos los
niños si él sabe lo que pasa y lo que
vemos nosotros la frontera en arizona y
en tejas lo que es la violación es
constante el secuestro de menores que
más del 60 por ciento de los niños
vienen no acompañados y son niños además
que lo hemos visto en imágenes esos días
y se les abandona es cierto eso no puede
ser
claro es entendible la situación en la
frontera es crítica mariah y lo peor
está por venir una vez se ha levantado
este título pues claramente muchas
personas intentarán ingresar a eeuu eso
me lleva a la pregunta que le quiero
hacer a mauren de la situación que puede
vivir méxico una vez este título se ha
levantado que el peso va a caer sobre
este gobierno el gobierno del presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador y las
autoridades mexicanas para hacer frente
a lo que se puede llegar a presentar
allá en la frontera lo pregunto porque
si en eeuu hay preocupación por la
llegada masiva de las personas pues en
qué escenario va a quedar méxico y
también los países de centroamérica
desde dónde van a empezar a salir las
caravanas
yo creo que de eso por eso están estas
reuniones están tienen el gobierno de
eeuu el secretario mayor que visitó a
méxico recientemente
en costa rica acaban de firmar una
de acuerdo de inmigración y protección
con costa rica por ejemplo y pensando en
planes por por ejemplo en méxico que
tendrían que tener en la estructura en
su lado de la frontera para atender a lo
que podría ser un mayor flujo de
personas es importante resaltar que eeuu
apoya bastante al sistema de protección
en méxico a través de la acnur a la
agencia de méxico a la tomar para apoyar
a refugiados también estamos apoyando al
acnur en toda la región para dar
atención a muchas personas incluso a las
personas venezolanas que están en
colombia y en otros países en américa
sur yo creo que justamente el dueño de
vaina está pensando que hay que
enfrentar esta situación de diferentes
vertientes coronados y ver cómo mejorar
la infraestructura en el en la frontera
por otro lado están reformando el
sistema de asilo para que las personas
nuevas que están llegando van a hacer su
proceso en seis meses y las personas que
no podrían calificar los van a regresar
a sus países de origen también cómo
cooperar con américa central hay que
recordar que fue alguna acción que cortó
la ayuda a centroamérica el gobierno d
ha estado dando un medio mil millones de
dólares en asistencia cada año para
atender las causas de raíz de la
migración incluyendo la crisis
humanitaria de diferentes países
provocado por el cambio climático están
apoyando y buscando estos acuerdos con
diferentes países para justamente ver
esto no solamente como un tema de qué
pasa en la frontera de eeuu sino cómo
asegurar que la gente tenga condiciones
en sus países de origen para no tener
que huir
de buscar protección en otro lugar y
para también pensar que no solamente
tendrían que llegar a eeuu qué papel
tiene en méxico que ha recibido más de
130 mil personas solicitantes de asilo
el año pasado pero también países como
costa rica lo que comentó la otra para
listar sobre colombia reciba más de un
millón de personas venezolanas como
apoyar esos países también para que esa
gente migrante tengan o si debe quedarse
allí y tener una vida digna
entiendo el punto mauren importante
destacar la posición de méxico un país
que ha estado luchando también con este
tema de la migración pero muchos lo
critican mauren por algunas de las
políticas que ha instaurado sobre todo
hacia los ciudadanos centroamericanos lo
critican de ser un país duro y de
dejarle la carga a estos países para
enfrentar la situación méxico no se ha
lavado las manos sobre esta situación
claramente
no en méxico hay muchos problemas de
abuso contra personas migrantes que
están en tránsito por méxico hay muchos
retrasos en la situación de solicitantes
de protección en méxico miles de
personas varadas en el sur de méxico
creo que méxico tiene mucho que hacer
también tiene que cooperar más con
centroamérica en estos temas y hay que
recordar eeuu tanto con méxico como con
los gobiernos centroamericanos y está
trabajando en cómo colaborar más en
temas de desarrollo con méxico también
acordaron a través de la agencia
desarrollo de méxico a nextel el año
pasado buscar como colaborar con
centroamérica y también existen fuerzas
de tarea que están buscando cómo
comparar para temas de tráfico y trata
de personas y cómo desmontar mantener
estas redes e investigar a las personas
que están cometiendo los abusos contra
personas migrantes en todo ese corredor
de tránsito de personas migrantes mariah
en la ciudad de miami en el estado de la
florida le pregunto ahora por el el peso
político que representa esto para la
administración actual esto que costó
puede representar para el presidente by
de ésta
jugándose una carta muy importante en un
momento donde su popularidad no es alta
y donde la agenda internacional está
también nacional está enrutada en la
situación en ucrania en terminar de
salir de la pandemia en reactivar la
economía del país y este tema parece
volverse otra complicación en la agenda
como lo ve usted
asimismo sanz no es un tema adicional es
que el problema es que la inmigración
ahora mismo se ha convertido en un
cáncer el tema de la inmigrante la
crisis fronteriza porque además es algo
que como yo decía es una hipocresía ir a
defender la frontera de ucrania cuando
tenemos está esta frontera en nuestra
abierta ahora mismo en el que muchas
personas recordemos que incluso hace un
año estamos hablando de los
hacinamientos de los centros de menores
supuestamente este trato más humanitario
más digno equivale a esta administración
es completamente inexistente no existen
los menores siguen hacinados sean
mandaron menores a las bases militares
se han mandado menores sin tener todos
los datos y hay familiares
están ahora mismo llegando sin
acompañantes sin adultos a informes de
muchísimo tráfico de menores de
compraventas de personas en fin es una
cosa terrible esta administración no
sólo nos ha metido en esta peor crisis
migratoria sino estaba viviendo de nuevo
en el ámbito de la inflación la peor
inflación de los últimos 40 años
política exterior abandonamos miles de
millones de dólares en material
en material militar es una debacle en
afganistán no supimos reaccionar
rápidamente para detener la invasión de
rusia ucrania en fin en lo que se está
viviendo aquí es muy grave y yo creo que
lo van a pagar mucho porque el problema
es que no están no están sabiendo
reaccionar a tiempo sobre todo los
precios de la gasolina ahora si libera
el petróleo pero cerraste el gasoducto
en fin es es mucho lo que está pasando
en este país y como tú decías santiago
los índices de popularidad están mínimos
mínimos históricos- los hispanos si ven
ustedes las encuestas
a los demócratas está completamente
obsesionado que a los hispanos nos
preocupa el tema de la inmigración
cuando uno ve las encuestas reales la
inmigración está en el lugar número 8
nosotros en este país las preocupaciones
son económicas de salud en fin
emprendimiento política exterior
entonces yo creo que el partido
demócrata está completamente errado
sobre lo que de verdad nos importa a los
hispanoamericanos y recordarle que en
virginia ya vieron que el 54% de los
hispanos se volcó y votó por este nuevo
gobernador conservador y en lo que va a
pasar las elecciones al medio término
donald trump lo anunciado esta semana
él piensa correr para para la
candidatura de 2024 si recuperamos el
senado del congreso y el presidente país
se lo está poniendo en bandeja porque no
está haciendo nada para detener esta
crisis que estamos viviendo a todos los
niveles a todos los niveles son las
palabras de maría herrera llegamos ya a
la recta final del programa quiero que
vayamos llegando a las conclusiones
haciendo las conclusiones sobre este
tema comienzo con mauren en la ciudad de
washington preguntándole lo que usted
cree que puede llegar a suceder con el
levantamiento entonces de este título 42
en términos generales no tenemos bola de
cristal para ver el futuro y ver qué es
lo que va a pasar eso siempre lo digo
pero desde su análisis esto qué
consecuencias va a traer
a futuro en el mediano plazo claramente
el título va a ser levantado ya sea en
noviembre ya sea en mayo cuando el
gobierno lo decida pero esto va a traer
consecuencias en el mediano plazo
yo creo que por un lado importante
resaltar que nunca fue algo permanente y
no debe ciertamente porque fue con el
pretexto de la pandemia y seguramente va
a agregar más gente en unos meses a la
frontera esto queda claro están
preparando creo que el gran otra vez
reto para alguna de bailén es que vamos
a ver de aquí al 23 de mayo para ver
quién entra estructura tienen en la
frontera para poder procesar a la gente
de forma oportuna y humana y bastante
rápida para evitar estos sobre
sobrepoblación en el lado de eeuu pero
también creo que es importante o sea
parte de la de las personas que están
cruzando justamente porque les permite
expulsar se tan rápidamente 30 por
ciento de las personas que han sido
detenidas bajo el título 42 son personas
que tratarán de cruzar anteriormente en
los últimos meses o sea gente que cruza
una y otra y otra vez porque no hay
consecuencias porque no los están
expulsando sus países de origen entonces
porque vamos a ver una bajada de cierta
población que está buscando entre los
eeuu un número constante de personas
buscando protección
es menores no acompañados vulnerables
están oyendo la constitución que temen
por su vida y que quieren venir a eeuu
para protegerse y yo creo que como me
pregunto de mediano plazo creo que
justamente ese reto el gobierno de
bairén piensa en algo de mediano plazo
sobre cooperación con centroamérica
sobre un acuerdo regional en manejo
migratorio es un tema que va a firmar
también un acuerdo o un marco regional
en el contexto la cumbre las américas en
los ángeles en junio de este año pero
creo que el reto es justamente que va a
pasar un corto plazo porque seguramente
va a haber mucha gente llegando y el
reto para el gobierno es pongo mantener
ese control y en coordinación de entre
sus agencias y también con la sociedad
civil estados pues a planear a las
personas están llegando es claro ese
reto a corto plazo es estar listos para
lo que pueda suceder en la frontera tan
pronto el título sea levantado a mediano
plazo pues ya lo hemos el manejo de la
situación entonces con quienes ya llegan
allí y con los que están pensando en
irse de sus países de origen y tratar de
entrar a estados unidos a través del
territorio mexicano para la conclusión
cierro entonces con maría herrera de
miami que va a suceder en el mediano
plazo el costo político esto ya lo
mencionábamos pero pensando un poco más
allá proyectando un poco más allá esto
que va a significar para eeuu las
previsiones apuntan a que se va a
incrementar la inmigración ilegal y
desordenada en un 40 por ciento para la
primavera esto es que va a conseguir va
a conseguir que la sociedad
estadounidense se revuelva que haya una
migración de los votantes demócratas que
se conviertan en independientes e
incluso en republicanos en conservadores
y esto va a fomentar que los
gobernadores de estados como florida
texas arizona los candidatos en nuevo
mexico se unan para denunciar esto los
proyectos de ley además que preveían lo
que tenían en mente es proponer
cualquier reforma inmigratoria para una
posible regularización masiva de
inmigrantes van a quedar estancados la
división y los insultos la en fin el
perjudicado va a ser en primer lugar el
inmigrante y en segundo lugar por
supuesto la sociedad estadounidense que
vuelve a dividirse en un tema que
deberíamos de estar unidos la
inmigración humanitaria sí pero sobre
todo en migración legal ordenada en
cooperación con otros países y nuestra
defender nuestras fronteras y antes ante
todo una emigración organizada un tema
que ha sido una deuda pendiente para
eeuu no solamente para este gobierno
sino para otros amaría y amaury les
agradezco para haber estado con nosotros
aquí en el programa haber hecho este
análisis para nuestra audiencia en toda
américa latina' ustedes pueden seguir
dejando sus comentarios a través de las
redes sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]